Hé bien bonjour les amis et bienvenue à...
Chuis un peu loin, salut !
Maxime, Amixem il est là.
Amixem est ce que tu sais ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui?
Ouais on va composer une musique en 1h.
C'est faux, tu peux partir par là bas.
Cool !
Allez à bientôt Maxime
Tu n'as pas du tout parlé de ce bureau  en fait ?
Ha oui c'est vrai !
On a volé le bureau de Mcfly et Carlito parce que...
le mien était trop bas
Bref !
C'est un jeu pour enfant de 7 ans et demi
Appuie sur ce bouton
*Amixem content* Yes !
*rires*
Excellent !
Et tu dois faire des petits à-coups
Et quand il va venir vite (rire)
Il va falloir le lâcher
pour qu'il atterrisse correctement là bas.
On est sur un double bouton, ok.
Voilà, là par exemple j'ai raté.
Dès que l'un de nous réussit à faire un salto et.. et à le voir atterrir comme ça
ou comme ça.. ou comme ça
non ça c'est faux
Dès que tu réussis tu as le droit de faire un tweet avec mon compte twitter,
dès que je réussis j'ai le droit de faire un tweet avec ton compte twitter.
Très bien ça me va.
C'est comme Mcfly et Carlito avaient fait
"Gymnaste twitter"
"Gymnaste bottle flip challenge twitter"
Pourquoi il ne se passe rien ?
Tu peux faire un tour même, si t'es  chaud.
HOOO !
*bruit de ralenti*
Ho dommage c'est le plat !
Euh...on va passer des heures sur ça.
je t'avoue un secret hier j'ai testé et j'y arrivais pas
c'est un secret très court
*rires*
(petit rire) A aucun moment il a envie de poser ses pieds sur le tapis.
Mec ! (rire)
Le premier qui va le poser ça va être...
- Ah mec ça va être fou j'ai pas envie...
- Il va mériter son tweet !
*bruit de ralenti*
Mec j'ai trouvé ça beau
Franchement c'était beau, y avait de l'ergonomie, mais c'est.. mais c'est nul.
Put !
Mec ça aurais été beau !
T'es sur qu'on va pouvoir tweeter dans cette vidéo ?
Oui
*rires*
Ce cadre est vraiment beau.
Ce cadre est très beau !
Ohh ! J'ai le droit à un tweet quand même pour ça où pas ?
Non
*chuchote* merde...
Lance-le maintenant faut que t'y aille
*appuie plusieurs fois...*
Mais j'appuie mille fois sur ce bouton là !
Mais mec on va faire aucun tweet
C'est quand même le plus drôle de la vidéo de faire des tweets.
Bah oui mais y en a pas pourquoi apparemment  pour le moment (*rires*)
*Grincements*
*rires*
J'ai envie de t'offrir un tweet juste pour ça.
3 essais chacun on.. on vient de l'intégrer.
*musique classique + le bruit du jouet qui tombe (c'est entraînant du coup...beaucoup trop entrainant même *
3 essais ! On a dit 3 essais !
Ok ! *rires*
Parce que là !
*Lucas qui rigole derrière*
J'en ai marre OK ?!
*c'est reparti pour la musique *
les enfants ils peuvent pas s'amuser parce que là ils sont censé faire des points,
mais encore faut-il..
*rires*
Y a des points selon la.. la distance à laquelle tu vas non mais mec !  *rires*
Juste réussir 1 fois c'est incroyable !
* musique classique et bruit du jouet *
*rires*
- Journée de m*rde !
- On parle même plus,
les mec ne parlent même plus c'est génial !
*musique classique ( et oui encore et toujours dans ces moment )*
*cri de joie de Squeezie *
*rires*
*s'arrache la gorge de rire*
*rires + la désespérance d'Amixem*
Qu'est ce que c'est mérité tiens j'te file mon compte youtube (sa casquette me stress)
*rire*
Donne moi tout ! J'veux ton compte en banque, j'veux tout ! (Fais pas la michtoneusse Lucas)
Et j'crois que j'ai trouvé la technique
Ah bah je crois aussi  *rire*
Tu fais attention quand même ?
Ouais j'mets pas un truc de ouf t'inquiète
*rire étrange *
*rires*
Ah elle a été longue à démarrer la vidéo !
Aller on enchaîne ! Ouais mais si j'enchaîne c'est grillé !
*lecture des réponses*
Ah si elle savait. Si elle savait !
Mec c'est dur de me rattraper !
Non par contre 3 essais..
Mais mec tu l'as cassé !
*rires*
Hé t'as vu il fait comme tes miniatures... il met des flèches rouges !
Ooooooooh !
Non en vrai j'ai fait la même...
- Par contre on peut changer de gymnaste ou pas ?
- Ah c'est la faute du gymnaste !
Moi quand je me fais inviter à ce genre de jeu, je prends mon propre gymnaste tu vois
Allez concentre toi, concentre toi !
*frappe dans ses mains*
voilà ,voila, voila, voi
*ralenti*
mais quelle vitesse quelle rapidité d’exécution ! Pourtant rien !
Allez
Mais mec ! *rires*
*ralenti*
*rires*
Quel dommage !
Donne une impulsion.
Fais toi plaisir !
C'est un peu fort là
Sur les mains !
On est tous là on passe un très bon moment, on s'amuse tous beaucoup !
Et toi y compris d’ailleurs et tes abonnés qui se disent
"P*tain mais quel bon guest il a, il a vraiment bien fait, il a choisit le bon jeu et le bon guest c'est nickel, l'osmose est.. parfaite".
J'regarde pas c'est peut être mon regard qui te dérange.
Mec !
Tweet avec mon compte tiens je te l'ouvre !
Tu peux le faire concentre toi !
Toujours la même, toujours la même
*rires + jeu qui se fout d'Amixem*
Maxime !
- C'est fou de ne pas réussir après 200 essais mec !
- Mais arrête
J'peux jouer contre moi même ?
- Ouais vas-y.
- Ok
Quand est-ce que t'appuies, quand est-ce que t'appuies !
A quel moment tu app..
Ohh bien joué tu m'as eu !
Fais un tweet s'te plait. J'te l'offre  j'espère que ça te fera du bien
*voix très virile * Oh b*taaard !
Oh bien joué !
Oh y'a un "j'avoue", m*rde ! Mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait !
Mec !
Tu ramasses
Est-ce que, après avoir fais cette vidéo, tu vas acheter le jeu de société ou pas ?
Oh oui !
*rires*
je vais clairement acheter un Docteur Maboule ou un Uno comme tout le monde
*cris de victoire de Amixem*
Attends attends !
J'veux prendre une photo !
Je prends une photo.
Oh merci mec !
Tu vois quand ça ira mal dans ma vie je regarderai cette photo et je me souviendrai,
j'ferai : "franchement t'as connus pire Lucas"
t'as connus pire
allez deuxième tweet pour toi adjugé
"The Kairi78 dispo en mp ? c'est pour une vidéo ensemble"
En plus t'écris en me regardant t'es insolent !
Oh ouais. Oh ouais le 100 en vachement..
Face ! Face a la caméra sur le 100 points mec là...
C'est un tweet ça.
Alors je veut juste voir les réponses vite fait de ce que les gens t'ont mis
MAIS NAN !
Oh mec c'est fou !
Il nous a vendu !
un tweet !
Nan vraiment, j'insiste.
30 minutes comme ça et t'as eu le temps de faire hop là
*Lis son tweet*
C'est tweeté !
Alors tu sais quoi ? On fait un double, c'est fou.
Moi j'ai un désavantage c'est que je dois le faire a l'envers c'est super ch*ant...
Gnagnagna
Pardon ?
*rires*
Pourquoi 3 d'ailleurs ?
Oh p*tain ça m'a foutu un coup de jus dans le brAaaAs...
Vraiment ?
Oui
T'as vu ma voix est partie en co*ille c'est que j'ai eu vraiment mal
C'qui est bien c'est vu qu'il y a deux jeux il y en a plus un de nous pour animer la vidéo *rire*
Allez ! Allez Maxime !
Ça devient gênant. Tu peux aller même dans mes mp si tu veux.
Je vois que ça s'envoie des grosses photos de villa c'est quoi ça ?
C'est ma maison, c'est ma...
J'ai juste envoyé un petit "Mec t'abuses" à VodKa.
Tu sais quoi je vais nous chercher des sandwichs, mais pour de vrai hein !
Ch*er !
- Eh j'entends crier de dehors ! (Squeezie)
- Bonjour
- Bon moi j'suis un peu moins cool il y a vait pas de thon-mayo, y'avait que du jambon-beurre
* Amixem content *
Mais il t'fallait un sandwich !
- Merci mec !
- Il t'fallait un sandwich !
- Yesss !
- Mais nan la caméraaa !!!
-Quoi? Depuis quand?
- Personne ne te croira !
- On a le son, on a la preuve...
Lucas m'a amené un sandwich, j'ai appuyé sur le bouton j'ai fait ça.
- J'peux essayer une fois ?
- Vas-y.
Mais là ça filme hein ça filme bien c'est sûr ?
- Oui oui moi il y a pas de soucis
- Là il y a pas de problème de record
T'as fait une vidéo où t'as dis que tu ferais que des vidéos qui plaisaient,
c'est à dire celle-là avec moi..
- Ah bah par exemple celle-là elle est.. *rires*
Et du coup j'vais tweeter "j'ai changé d'avis (*ah l'b*tard !*), à partir de demain, une vidéo par jour"
Et si on regarde les réponses un petit peu au tweet
"Attends quoi ?" Oh oui ! Oh j'ai crée le doute !
T'as créé une embrouille regarde "Tg", "ferme ta grosse g*eule",  "calme ta ch*tte"
T'as créé une embrouille !
J'ai une idée. Le prochain qui réussit, il doit faire un périscope, où il fait semblant de pleurer, d'être mal,
Je sais très bien que c'est moi qui vais faire le live, donc heu.. *rires*
Eh mec, téma comment tu l'as mis par terre ! C'est fou tu as réussi
Ohh ! Oh p*tain on peut pas filmer ça fait ch*er
- Il le met juste sous le bureau !
- Il est debout !
*musique épique*
"Tu peux le faire concentre toi !"
Allez concentre-toi, concentre-toi
Allez ! Allez Maxime !
Bouuuuuuuum !
Attends si j'y arrive..
- Ouais mais tu y arrives pas.
*Musique triste*
*rire de Maxime*
- Mais mec tu perds.. Pendant toute la vidéo..
- Yesss !
Il perd pendant toute la vidéo j'vais lui acheter des sandwich tellement on a du mal !
Il était hyper bon en plus !
Du coup j'peux t'prendre en photo ?
Moi quand j'irai pas bien, eh bah je ressortirai cette photo et j'me dirai, j'me dirai
"t'en as ch*é mais t'as fini par y arriver"
*rires*
Est-ce qu'on peut parler de tes auréoles vite fait ?
- Alors j'en ai parlé pendant que tu étais pas là.
Mec j'ai tellement chaud à force de faire ce jeu j'ai des auréoles elles font 6 hectares !
On a tous rigolé, les gens en ont parlé dans les commentaires
J'me suis dis si j'en parle pas les gens vont parler que de ça !
Fatigué un peu ouais..
Ça va pas de ouf j'vous avoue ça va pas de ouf, j'suis pas très heu..
J'suis pas très chaud aujourd'hui
Merci pour les cœurs c'est gentil
"What happened ?" bah c'est chaud.. j'suis pas heuu.. j'en ai marre, j'ai envie un peu de tout arrêter heuu.. Voilà.
Nan j'suis juste pas très en forme je..
J'suis saoulé !
"On dirait que tu vas pleurer". Nan mais ça va, c'est.. C'est passé.
*petit rire de Maxime*
*Maxime tousse*
Mais regardez-le ! Regardez-le c'b*tard !
J'étais.. j'avais un gage je devais faire ça c'était ignoble !
- Désolé tout va bien ! Vous en faites pas !
- Y'en avait plus d'un qui y croyait
Y'en a plus d'un qui y croyait j'suis désolééé
bon les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu
Ça m'a brisé le cœur, les gens je les voyais ils faisaient "ça va pas, qu'est-ce que t'as, t'as pleuré ?"
- Merci Amixem de m'avoir rejoint
- Un plai-sir merci de m'avoir invité
Heu choisis un autre jeu la prochaine fois j'te dis Docteur Maboul ou Uno quand tu veux *rires*
A bientôt les gens sur l'Périscope, et puis heu, gros bisous !
- 'Tends on va nous entendre en écho ça va être un peu gênant
- Mais c'est fou c'est terrible !
".. Toujours en Périscope
- Si jamais.. Oui on est toujours en Périscope.
A bientôt les gens sur l'Périscope, et puis heu, gros bisous !